he's funny I'd like to see it he hinted
so but even but even like they're like
Christie Leah's dad's super success yeah
there's one of the funniest people I
know yeah but he there must have been
some sort of darkness or void attention
that you seek and becomes that yeah but
that's two different things that cuz
bill is a producer director and Chris is
a stand-up I'm just saying his dad was
super successful entertainer oh I see
what you're saying you know you know he
didn't come from like this this struggle
where he's like I gotta figure it out
because I'm sure Chris can add other
plans where he could have got a job with
his dad or something I think his only
struggle Chris's only struggle is that
his brothers better looking than him his
brothers yeah Matz Matz a much better
looking family member I think he's the
best-looking one out of the two and I
think any other I think that that [ __ ]
with Chris have [ __ ] with Chris at how
he's straight now his brother start his
own podcast - yeah and that's gonna
probably yeah Matt D'Elia Matt - Lia
yeah we get a picture of Madeline there
he is
Jesus Christ where's mad at there's Matt
right there look at [ __ ] it's like
it's like Matt and then Jesus Christ I
mean and then there's Chris Doering
Murray you shouldn't move in Albuquerque
right a big movie oh that's awesome yeah
you think I love Chris man I remember
when I saw him at uh haha and I was you
know I was I was already how long doses
this is about 12 years ago you know I
was I was starting to become a like that
there's Chris yeah I'm in on that he's
on the backup begun the post yeah
there's Chris what are you gonna say
though I saw him at the hahaha there's
about 12 years ago I think and I'm
starting to headline in props and and I
just go there it's like it's like a
Wednesday you know I mean and and I see
Chris go up there and there's like five
people you know the ha the old ha ha by
the way so and I just remember there's
like 5 people and he's killing like he's
you know I mean and I walked up to him I
was just like I've met him a couple
times before through Jason Collins and
then I was just like hey you want to go
on the road with me like open for me
like you're funny dude
and uh and I just that's what I was like
I want to I want this in front of me
yeah I mean like this is gonna step my
game up so yeah he's he's he's always
been a killer he's so funny man I took
him on the road for about a year and a
half year and a half yeah then but did
he go from he went with you and then
they was on the road with Brian and um
that was later later was that later
later yeah yeah yeah he he was on the
road with me initially like that I think
that was his first time out on the road
and doing a like improv and [ __ ] like
that and would you guys hang out a lot
always yeah that's all we did miss good
hang oh yeah yeah it was fun and you
know he was a baby then that's when he
was young yeah I think he was only in
for a couple years three years here's
the thing with Eminem was not 20 he's
just I told him - I went you gotta
realize I kept I can't my last time a
comic did something that would that
explores like that's the biggest thing
man I need you to know how big that is
yeah that's Eminem played you because
you did something silly in your car and
pretend you're Eminem now Eminem
pretended he was actually I do you
realize how big Daddy oh it's great yeah
of course man he's [ __ ] that's not
even iconic anymore that's a god that's
nice he's a rap guy level but uh but
what my favorite one that he did was the
one in the garage of his house I think
that's the one we like the other ones
before that we're just okay the one in
the garage it's amazing I [ __ ] I
remember I remember texting and going I
can't stop laughing
it's like so funny man do more of these
please since BAM can ah this is so
[ __ ] stupid
yeah he's stupid so yeah yeah yeah what
a compliment Scott he's stupid it's the
best combo we can do yeah yeah Nataly
everybody yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[ __ ] business